so here's another in a sense national
policy question from Kevin Kelly can we
learn anything about reforming
capitalism from China right so you know
my previous book was called
entrepreneurial state and when I think
of China I think of the adaptive States
China really interestingly I think is
learning from the US in a moment that
the u.s. is unlearning from itself it's
it's it struck me that the first thing
Trump did when he came into office was
actually attacked particular public
organizations arpa-e and PBS and what
China's been doing you know and I think
there's a question or whether it's gonna
be successful or not it's forming
actually quite active investor kind of
innovative public organizations but
they're huge they're huge it's not a
decentralized network of public
organizations across the whole
innovation chain as we had in the US so
the Chinese Development Bank is a
massive financial institution which has
provided loans up to nine billion for
many of its companies including wha why
why why wouldn't exist without the
Chinese Development Bank by the way
Huawei which is on the news a lot is a
cooperative can you believe that I mean
they it was quite fun oh sorry
in Dalian I met I we they had a tea
ceremony in Dalian China because the
World Economic Forum has a youth
component that meets and Dalian and and
Huawei executives asked me and three
other economists this was back in I
think 2013 to meet with them to say what
should we do about the US it was very
strange I mean thinking about what's
happening now and what do you mean like
well yeah it's really hard in the u.s.
it's we're not really penetrating the
market and my advice was tell them you
are cooperative I mean just in terms of
kind of getting you know what I think is
interesting in China is there's a lot of
variety there's not one model there's
lots of different types of organizations
hence the hallway example it's a
cooperative there's state-owned
companies there's companies that are
actually going more towards slowly I
think a more market-driven and
anglo-saxon model of us but there's
variety there there's also much more
Mayer
talk recei in terms of who works in
governments than we have in many
countries in the UK there's very little
matter autocracy in terms of who
actually rises up in government there's
lots of experiments actually at the
community level but it is also you know
it's it's you know has problems of
democracy so it's not it's not one you
know it's not a cut and paste model from
you know communist versus capitalist but
how it evolves the degree to which there
is engagement you know for example
they're spending 1.7 trillion on
greening their economy coming back to
the green missions and this is out of
urgency mm-hmm and it's really
interesting how also in the u.s. big
things happen when there is urgency you
know when there's war and if you've seen
also the documentary on the Roosevelts
it's fantastic when there was urgency
big things happen in the US and so the
degree to which this urgency creates
because of pollution is creating both
are very positive change so 1.7 trillion
on greening the economy including energy
friendly technologies not just renewable
energy but also kind of that rush to
create and invest in and not focus on
really rebalancing the whole economy for
example around consumption and services
is is causing the economy to be
unbalanced